[Music]
Zach bamburger it's so good to have you
here how are you I'm well uh thanks for
having me yeah yeah well as can be in
this time and thank you for all the for
all the amazing work that we're doing
social media for Israel it's such an
awesome initiative I I'm honored to to
take a a small part of it myself and and
it's incredible to see to see the energy
that's ensuing on our slack Channel and
all the amazing things happening from
the tech pers all the way from the tech
perspective all to the actual execution
and
productionize that this is moving at I
think it's probably faster than most
startups I got to to see and follow and
so I'm I'm very excited to dive into
this with you and you know going back a
little bit tell me a little bit about
yourself and perhaps a little bit about
you know your team members and you know
where you know what what are you doing
in the world these days outside of the
War uh sure so um I'll start with myself
I'm uh I'm finishing up my masters at
the tech neon I uh originally I guess
I'm an Israeli American uh grew up in
hia I studied in the states a little bit
um at Cornell and then I worked for a
couple of years at Google in California
before deciding to do the whole uh MSC
PhD thing here I was really passionate
about natural language processing and uh
figured that um it would be good to come
home and work with uh someone like my
current adviser yonathan
binkov um and uh yeah that that kind of
covers me I think um when it comes to
some of my uh teammates um I have to
shout out NV who is basically leading
everything that uh has to do with
building our platform front end backend
scraping everything that's been him um
and we have an amazing uh Team of uh
researchers who've uh volunteered to
help us Stanford posts uh other Stanford
students I guess it runs strong with you
as well um and uh people from industry
Microsoft Google it seems like everybody
is just coming together to uh try to
help yeah can you can you go back and to
Saturday morning when this all started
and where sort of where were you how you
know what did that what did this catch
you what were you doing um I was uh I
was in Vietnam I was uh my first
vacation in about 2 years oh wow
um I was um I was there with my partner
we were um in Hoi Min City um you know
we had tourist plans and uh we started
hearing news at a certain point it was
the afternoon for us it was 4 hours
ahead and we were just shocked and we
were just our eyes were stuck to our
phones um we immediately called her
families in her case it was difficult
because um some of her family keeps
Shabbat um
so we felt a kind of hopelessness um uh
inability to help and um I guess I grew
tired of that really quickly and tried
to figure something else that I could do
with all these emotions and uh figured
that if I can't help you know like the
traditional uh you know in the
traditional way of army uh service here
in Israel I can try to use what I know
technologically in order to try to help
and I have experience um in the hpar uh
front of things um already from my days
in college fighting uh misinformation
from students for justice in Palestine
and the boycott divestment and sanctions
movement wow okay and so you know the
when this whole thing started
um Gathering the initial group of people
you had you know bringing in the idea
what was that experience like walk me
through the the formation of this
project so I I think it all really
started when um I started writing some
code myself just for a simple tool for
translating posts from uh from Hebrew or
Arabic to English just to try to broaden
the impact of posts that I you know kept
on seeing that were really good uh in
Hebrew or automatically translated on
you know like on some other from some
other source uh to English and I I
understood that the quality was good but
that it wasn't really accessible to the
crowd of people that but what happens
when you trans what was going to happen
once you translate it to English so you
get you you see an amazing po you you so
you scrap the posts that are Hebrew and
Arabic that are not accessible
necessarily to The Wider Western public
you're translating them to English
you're starting to write code on this
yourself and what is meant to happen
with the post that you identify as high
quality um
I mean there there are a few metrics
that we're looking at here so is it pro
or anti-israel it is it um does is it
popular now and also um are we
predicting that it will become viral in
the near or longer future which is
another metric that we're looking at and
we try to prioritize uh posts that are
viral in anti-israel for a pipeline that
we have for reporting but that's
something that came later the original
thing was to try to take posts that are
pro-israel and uh potentially viral in
Hebrew and try to translate them to
English so that they can gain traction
among International crowd um and when we
posted that or when I posted that online
in the mdli communitya mdli community
just a ton of people what's the mdli
community uh the mdli community is the
Israel machine learning and data science
community and it includes thousands of
people um really really passionate
scientists sta scientists researchers
Engineers um and everybody just jumped
on board from there incredible okay so
you're you started off quing yourself
did you have a did you realize you're
trying to create now a group how many
people are involved in this now um just
the research team is about 35 active
people um when it when we look at our
WhatsApp group um we're about 120 or so
people and the development team is also
like a separate entity and we try to
collaborate with each other as much as
what was so what was the shift for you
when you when did this become not no
longer a a Zach um you know project to
now at this is actually a big movement
that today we're going to talk soon
about the potential impact but I'm
convinced it has the potential to make
incredible impact I I'll be honest with
you very quickly um I mean I was Str
struggling to try to get you know my
flight ticket tickets to try to get back
to Israel so that I could be back and
next to my family you were doing that in
Vietnam still yeah wow all of this was
on the first day in Vietnam um so it was
I was kind of juggling between the two
and that's when Neil um and alel and
some of the other like early people just
jumped on board and uh and started
helping and taking on leadership roles
and I mean everybody just wanted to help
as much as they could they understood
everybody's constraints there was a
common understanding that we were all
volunteers um and so everybody was just
offering a helping hand I'll cover for
you if you're not available in these
hours I'll take on this role um that's
kind of how it started and it grew with
that mentality and how do and how do you
how did you start thinking about
managing you know research with
volunteers you mentioning you know the
covering of ours but a lot of this is
you know you're writing new new tools
that didn't necessarily exist before
you're you know in hard you're talking
about you know different languages and
soon we'll talk about the larger
emission but from from even a leadership
perspective how do you how do you manage
team of dozens of researchers that are
volunteer based some of them I guess are
in reserves some of them are are working
in the day today how do you m manage
through
that um so first of all understand your
audience the community of researchers
first of all they care deeply about
their country yeah um they have the same
Basic Instinct of wanting to fight and
defend um what they consider part of
their identity um and they're also very
passionate about particular Fields so
the objective was to try to give people
a way to positively um you know impact
the pro-israel narrative on social media
using a skill that they value
tremendously and that they think could
be impactful and integrated into a
platform and it was important to be able
to synchronize uh the idea a for a kind
of Technology with um how it will
actually be accessible to our audience
um and what are our basic principles for
example we're building a a language
model to do this translation do we trust
it 100% no so how about we find a bunch
of volunteers expert translators to
verify it first and then run statistical
experiments until we can't distinguish
between the quality of our human
translators and the quality of our
language models at that point we can
make that transition but until that
point we improve the model through
iterative uh you know experimentation
with different prompts different base
models and perhaps uh knowledge
injection and other um state-of-the-art
methods I don't think we're doing
anything new we're not inventing the
wheel here we're just using technologies
that are at the Forefront of artificial
intelligence for a goal that I don't
think it's been used for before nearly a
military goal
incredible okay so now let's talk
broader about the mission and the vision
for for what this what what what you're
doing here so it has a it has a name it
has a you have a almost a brand it's
it's an entity it's a movement that's
Way Beyond what it started with so share
with me a little bit about what is it
what is it that it is today nine eight
and a half days after you said okay I'm
going to go at
something um so social media for Israel
is a community of
volunteers uh with two main branches um
the development Branch led by neiv and
the research branch that I'm uh trying
to organize um I I can speak a little
bit about my group um we are about four
different um research managers or
research leaders as we like to say and
each one of us at the very least has an
MSC and some industry experience as well
IBM eal poly techniques data gen
Microsoft um and my experience with the
Google and what have you so a bunch of
experience and we defined a whole bunch
of uh projects and people um with
amazing amazing credentials you know
also from you know schools like Stanford
and teon and Ben gulon and all these
companies they um volunteer on
individual projects that we've laid out
um and we coordinate that with the
development team uh to iteratively
introduce what we show as proof of
concept demos into our uh platform so
again we platform and then you have
teams that are doing proof of Concepts
and this goes back to what you mentioned
before and identifying The Sweet Spot I
guess or aligning the passions of the
researchers with their respective Fields
so what's common I guess for all 130
people on the WhatsApp is that everybody
is fully dedicated to the mission of
preser of protecting their families and
Neighbors in our country and then you
add another layer on top of that at
fine-tuning you know the the the
specific poc's with the relative
passions and interests from a research
perspective of these groups do the PC
and then integrate them back into this
platform which is beautiful and it's
fast when people talk to me about the
fast how do you make it fast how do you
do research fast how do you do research
fast
um
you encounter a problem where if you
don't have it working you can't stop um
I'm not sure if you know like everybody
will necessarily understand that feeling
but for researchers I think it's very
common where you're just like okay I
have to make this work I'm not going to
sleep I'm not going to stop I maybe I
won't eat even though I'm hungry but
I've got to get this to work and I think
that a lot of people have gotten that
kind of mentality when they've been
working you know translation tool up in
like about a day V1 V2 uh you know like
actually using um an ensemble of
language Models Super quickly V2 you
know like
um and when it comes to say the
reporting tool I think that was also
done in a day the proof of concept there
so when you put people who really care
about what they're doing and see the
potential impact of it they love it they
they work hard on it and you know that's
what and and I'm the same you know my
passion project is persuasive
argumentation and that's going into this
as well and um when you're able to
express both your passion for an area of
interest and at the same time fight for
something that you really care about and
is you know Central to your identity
then you're very very motivated what are
some of the unique pcc's that you've
identified that are that went into the
platform and what is the what what how
is this platform going to start actually
executing in the day-to-day now sure so
um what we have right now live is the
ability to report posts that are either
Pro or
anti-israel um in this conflict in this
war um the thing that's coming out I
believe tomorrow is the ability to
actually have the translation tool where
um our translating experts will be able
to translate um manually um look over
translated posts make small uh changes
to them and um then they're submitted to
our system and shown to our viewers
um and again by having it go through our
experts we're actually gaining data in
order to be able to use um better
prompts and better models for the
particular tasks say one prompt uh might
be better when it comes to translate one
kind of phrasing might be better when
translating from English to French um
and worse when it comes to translating
from English to Spanish um or something
like that and these are things that
we're hoping to already integrate into
our data collection from day one um day
one of V1 not v0 which we are in now
um another thing that we have already
working demo but hoping to roll out soon
is again the reporting posting and uh
something that we're working on in
collaboration with AI 21 Labs is um the
post Improvement um kind of flow which
is basically you upload a pro-israel
post and you're able to make it um more
compelling from a narrative perspective
so it's not like you're answering an an
anti-israel post you're just
strengthening the tones and writing
style of a pro Israel post um and you
can see how with all of these different
features you can have iterations of
self-improvement or translation into
Improvement or you know what have you so
we're basically building these core
features into our platform and showing
them to our end users so that they're
able to act on social media that little
line I want to go up a little bit and uh
and and strategically and talk a little
bit about why this is important why is
this a you know you're spending so much
time on this and so many people are
spending so much time on this together
why why is this problem space that you
chose specifically around social media
narrative and variety of posts why is
this an important piece of the conflict
that we're
in um okay let's start with uh the
really really basic uh thing which is
basically public opinion matters um when
it comes to uh people who are going to
vote in the states um if they are just
Ed with posts that are very compelling
and anti-israel then that's where their
sentiment will shift and in order for
leaders to get elected then they will
have to align with that view in order to
adhere to Their
audience um so being able to kind of
combat that given the fact that there
are very few Jews in the world relative
to Muslims and predominantly Muslims
support uh the Palestinian cause and
Jews support the Israeli cause um I
think that there's a little bit of an
imbalance in power so being able to use
this technology to level the playing
field is important uh in addition to
that these Technologies are
generalizable broadly when it comes to
combating anti-Semitism in the
states um even outside of the context of
War um kind of making it very clear that
it's not okay um that certain narratives
of uh BDS are extremely harmful towards
peace um and that um certain narratives
of SJP as well are harmful and in that
sense maybe this tool is helpful to
preventing violence or of any kind
against Jews in the states MH and so if
you now think about you know the war is
going to be over hopefully sooner rather
than later and we will look back and
reflect what would have been an outcome
that you would tangibly feel um you know
happy content and fulfilled with looking
back at this at this massive project not
just you but you know the the hundreds
of people that by that time will have
taken part in
it I would like to know that I did what
I could to uh defend my country's
reputation um I don't agree with the
government but I side with the country I
um I don't want Israel to be known as a
country that is brutal in its responses
even though innocent people do die
um I think that people should recognize
Israelis as reasonable people um people
that want peace
um and in this case we're forced into
conflict um and that we're doing our
very best to minimize uh loss of uh
civilian life it's tragic on both ends
um so if if there's anything that we can
achieve um as an organization it's to
portray that point effectively and
combat misinformation which attacks that
perspective Zach I'm I'm so proud to
have had the chance to to share this uh
with others watching it and
participating as a part of this group is
is is an an inspiring feeling it's a
thrilling feeling H like I mentioned
before it's moving faster than I think
any startup that I've seen and I think
it's remarkable especially here where
you're able to take um deep technology
sometimes research integrate a large
group of people in on a many in on you
know all everybody on a volunteer basis
under a unified Mission and you're able
to actually execute to get into
production level um executable products
or systems that are not just you know
Concepts but actual tangible impactful
Technologies that's I think what's
really remarkable here beyond the the
what the reason to believe and the why
and the ire that you're having and I
think that that's just a um something to
look at you know in just in an inspiring
way from from startup nation and what
this represents and what happens when
you really get a group of people who
truly care about something and you put
them in the same room under a good
leadership with both technological
Vision but also real Humane Vision so um
thank you for inviting me to take part
of it and thank you for spending this
very precious time uh to talk about it
thank you for having me and uh it's a
pleasure to have you on board and being
able to identify deep fakes is uh really
important for our cause 100% thank you
[Laughter]
Zach